gathering the chinese products from
their homes and setting them on fire
burning effigies of president xi jinping
along with the chinese flag
or defacing billboards advertising
chinese products
people have protested across india
calling for both military and
economic action after 20 indian soldiers
were killed along the border with china
for the first time in 45 years
what china is doing at the border is
very unfortunate if a country is going
to treat india like an enemy
then we should also treat them the same
we should not have any trade relations
with china
it's a sentiment shared by many
including an influential group of
traders
it's launched a campaign asking movie
stars to stop advertising chinese
products
it's also asking 70 million members to
boycott
3 000 chinese products starting with
those which it says
can be replaced with indian made items
spending money on chinese products
is ultimately going to hit the country
because china will use that money either
to give
grants to pakistan for carrying out
terrorist activities in our country or
china will use
that money to put its forces against
indian forces
we asked the head of the traders
association if he'll stop using his
apple iphone given many are made or
assembled in
chinese food no china the parts are made
in china no not at all
india imports 70 billion worth of
products from china
southern bazaar is one of the biggest
markets in india selling
everything from household items to
electronics
toys clothes and cosmetics and like
other markets elsewhere which sell
things in bulk
and at low cost many of the products
here are made in china
shop owners say they support a boycott
of chinese products
whatever chinese stock we have we have
to sell after that we plan to no longer
buy chinese stock
and we'll make an effort to buy indian
made even if we make less profit
but others told us they couldn't make a
living if they didn't sell chinese-made
products but were afraid of saying that
in the current climate of
anti-china sentiment
china isn't just the biggest exporter to
india it's also a crucial investor in
some of its most successful
e-commerce companies i don't think it's
practical
because you know indian economy
is is very closely intellect
with the chinese economy and you know we
rely on china
for a lot of critical products it's not
easy to
really replace all the imports with uh
domestic products because you know you
need to invest heavily in domestic
you know manufacturing and that can't
happen in a hurry
so while people destroy chinese products
in public and the hashtag
boycott chinese products trends on
twitter the latest model of chinese
smartphone oneplus
sold out online in minutes elizabeth
peranom al jazeera new delhi